[Music]
all right y'all so uh
this has been going back and forth in
the news uh i know we've kind of brought
it up a couple times uh but today is not
so happy
um brittany greiner
we thought she was going to get
released for what was in arms traded you
thought it'd be she be traded
unfortunately she has now been sentenced
to nine years in russian prison so does
that mean they proved that she was in
possession of drugs well it's russian
prison yeah the gulag i don't think they
need that i think it's you don't really
have to prove it you know give me a
little recap i've been living under a
rock
so brittany griner is a wnba star okay
they oftentimes go to like russia during
the off-season and stuff like that to
play in just like different leagues and
stuff because obviously there's more of
a seasonal kind of thing for the league
over here she goes over there and she
has one of those like weed vape
cartridge type things on here right but
unfortunately timing and diplomacy and
politics plays a part in this one
because the russia ukraine war and the
position of the united states and stuff
like that you know in the face of
democracy and trying to support ukraine
makes it so it becomes a little bit of a
political standoff and an example when
they catch somebody like a brittany
grinder who has
a public face
so now it's not just like oh you know
this uh she's leveraged yeah she's
leveraged not just some random person
who did something it's like oh we can
use this because there's going to be
like public facing like backlash for the
american people especially if they don't
reach out and do something so they're
using her as leverage and there was a
moment actually like two weeks ago i
believe two or three weeks ago when
everybody thought that the trade was
going to happen for a russian arms
dealer it was going to be brittany
griner and it was like a negotiation for
it was like more than two people yeah
victor kalishnikov something like that
yeah yeah
frozen
i believe it yeah especially that outfit
how the how the turntables am i right
yeah
turn tables obviously they got to make
an example yeah britney griner and so
unfortunately now she is facing nine
years in a risk you know who you know
there's only one person that can solve
this it's steven seagal
that's true he's friends with yeah he's
actually friends with putin maybe jesse
ventura hey maybe robin get him in there
a little bit robin's a great diploma
robin could do it yeah and he also plays
basketball so he does plus he does he
knows about the game of basketball very
well yeah explain he could show putin a
couple things about that teacher it's a
trade that's part of the trip
you know it's crazy uh i looked up
brittany grimer reiner or griner griner
she could dunk pretty well
oh yeah wow that's pretty tight do you
know what the hoop height was on the
video oh it's standard bro like junior
high it's not the junior high courts it
was like it was like was it fisher price
it was play school i played
chris jesus but she was doing it between
her legs
she did the honey dip one which puts her
whole [ __ ] up she really
but all on the play school oh the play
school yeah yeah but she could she dunks
in games
she's watching this video looking at you
going nine years man getting out of here
nick done she's gonna kick my [ __ ]
ass bro
but this is a this is our chance for the
longest yard moment this is what's gonna
happen
yeah right longest yard ah dude cheer me
up that's the bright side she's gonna go
to the gulag they're gonna be like hey
you know the russian guy is gonna be
like hey uh
nice stuff basketball
i heard you're a basketball player
because she's literally the tallest
woman in russia for sure dude you guys
watch the video did you guys see the
video of her she's really getting walked
out with all the russian cards it looks
like you could just run away she could
beat all her [ __ ] assets she could
jump over her head and run and jump over
the border the walls only built two of
them
well they're they're built to standard
russian women height which is like four
foot five
dude that cell must be so cramped
russian women the the tallest russian
women before britain grinder showed up
was four foot five
that's the average height
freaking stats
wait so did any of you guys know who she
was prior to this news
that's why they don't allow women
drivers in russia because they can't see
over the steering wheel
yeah play [ __ ] nightmare but
just that they just look at the dash cam
they can only see the steering with the
lower part
so she's not like uh prior to this she
wasn't like uh
you know like what [ __ ] i'm trying to
name a wfba player i can't she's a big
she's whoops lisa leslie
she is a big deal in the wnba that's all
i got i didn't even mean to make fun of
that cheryl swoops no she is a big deal
in that she's she's a huge dick the
truth always makes fun of the wnba
harder than anything else yeah in my
opinion that's true yeah
so uh during the sentencing the judge
over there said that uh she had found
that grinder intentionally broke the law
and also fined her a million rubles
which is really about sixteen thousand
dollars now she's gotta do the
conversion too that's a pain in the
[ __ ] ass that's a pretty that's a
pretty like
does that get a little converted clear
[ __ ] up right like you bring drugs into
it it is it is it's a russia that's kind
of like like even if you go to malaysia
or singapore have you seen that sign at
the terminal it's it's literally like
you know like a like a don't walk thing
but it's a [ __ ] soldier silhouette
shooting like with a gun on a dude's
head and it says like trafficking
traffickers like no trial you just die
yeah wow yeah
it's just execution
you're like oh wow
wow that seems pretty cool they add
color to it so it's like red blood wait
this is what will happen [ __ ] it
and next to it there's like a no durian
science
you bring [ __ ] durian in here two
rules here
[ __ ] face
same thing blood
that better not be a dorian or meth
imagine being over there and you're like
what the [ __ ] going on there's about
this other guy on fire and like dorian
like oh [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] up
fire or you're like good
let me join in can i light them up
that definitely does suck but yeah it's
a freaking crime in another country what
can we do about it but apparently she
was playing over there
overseas a lot right yeah
again a lot of people do that uh off uh
off season right they they play in
different leagues they play in their
like home country
right a lot of international stars in
the nba go back to their home country to
play in their summer leagues and whatnot
but uh obviously
yeah ryan's right at the end of the day
like regardless of the situation
bringing drugs into a country doesn't
allow it there's how much time is she
doing so right now it's a nine and a
half year sentence
uh the nine year sentence was close to
the maximum 10 years the grinder had
faced under the charges prosecutors
asked for nine and a half year sentence
greiner's defense lawyer said they would
appeal and the defense team said that in
sentencing the court had ignored all
evidence it had presented and grinder's
guilty plea
damn they were really just like [ __ ]
they're like i don't care she pleaded
guilty
oh you got it no i did it i didn't get
it you didn't get it no you did it i
didn't man i wish you did sorry
all right she's clapping for the plea
um yeah uh the she she pleaded guilty
july 7th and since then they're they're
counting that towards the sentence date
but
is there any is there any type of thing
you know like here you get sentence like
25 years and then go oh you've been
pretty good you can go out to the public
after four or some sure i think in
russia you get a it's a week early
you do a full time there yeah yeah
they're like seven you get out like
seven days early what are what are
things that we know to be absolute
truths
about like russian prisons have you been
to russia oh i thought you're
have you because a lot of dancers i know
have been to russia
russia is very very different in the
winter and in the summer i'll tell you
that what do you mean like
one snows once sunny yeah you're very
good
[Laughter]
no it's not human no russia i mean
russia is a nice place you know in terms
of what i experienced being able to go
into places like moscow which has really
really terrible traffic by the way it
took like two hours to get like 30 feet
um worse than la yeah yeah in the thick
of it being a place like st petersburg
is beautiful
ecky terrenburg is some place i went
that's not so beautiful but still cool
a list of things not to do when you go
there
no no honestly i think one of the first
times i went to russia russia for the
dance community is one of those places
that like they bring you out first it's
like uh it's almost like one of the
earliest countries that brings people
out and it's almost a if you're a
choreography teacher if you will like
you almost have to pay your dues by
going through russia and then going to a
bunch of other like wow is there like a
big dance community there huge dance
community how many people just like damn
it you beat me
probably half of the country dresses
like stephen okay that's pretty pretty
good now russia's [ __ ] amazing
dancers so they have really really
strong big dance community stuff like
that but they bring you out and one of
my first experiences uh going out there
because i didn't know that we would have
to like you know travel by train from
city to city to go teach but they put
you on a train and then they have those
trains like in harry potter where it's
like four beds and stuff and
i got put on a train with three giant
russian dudes this really compact thing
and then it's like an overnight train
i've never [ __ ] traveled to teach
like this before and so like my entire
scope of russia was always like this is
a culture shock but i was accepted as
that you know what i mean same thing
like when you go to uh what is it the
not red square but um
whatever it is zangief
we're the main [ __ ] place where
london's buried and all of a sudden they
have that crazy um like uh candy castle
looking oh yeah yeah
yeah the kremlin area but like that one
particular building like that palace
thing
they're like one person uh who was our
host tetris yeah was telling us how uh
back in the day apparently it's like uh
they they made uh one a crazy architect
come in and build that very very special
thing for you know the russian
leadership and then after he had like
finished or the tsar or whatever after
he had finished building that he didn't
want that building or architecture style
replicated or anything like that so he
like ripped out the guy's eyes and like
killed him and his family or some [ __ ]
what a great thank you wave yeah you're
very russian oh that is a legendary
story
but so how was the food was the food
good yeah did they just eat caviar every
day they really like philadelphia uh
cheese uh
um sushi rolls philadelphia rolls oh i
love philly rolls [ __ ] up
this guy's rushing i get the california
roll and i get the philly roll that's
what i'm saying like a bunch of sushi
spots out there but it's only like the
westernized version do you think they
they only took your ass there because
they thought that you're gonna some
racist [ __ ]
they're like what this what do these
people eat i don't know
or whatever there's like bread soup yeah
well i'm not a huge fan of able to find
weed there at all
no no i wasn't
i wasn't looking nobody ever said hey
you want to smoke like casually europe
is all about spliffs though in general
so it's always like a little bit of weed
mixed with like tobacco everything's
about a spliff so you never like have
anything pure and at that time that i
was going there there were no things
like vape cartridges and stuff like that
so like finding weed is like really like
you got to really be looking for or like
be in that crowd of people i never i
never smoked me in russia is it true
that you have to do that dance move
which is like the [ __ ]
the russian leg kicking thing yeah when
you go like this that's just dope as
[ __ ] yeah have you seen it yeah where
they jump into like 540s and land on
their knees dance style that's just like
one move in that world but the rest of
the moves are way crazier than that
that's probably impressive that's right
the tamest one have you done it can you
guys do that not do that no i feel like
we all tried doing that in elementary
school yes that probably you gotta have
mozzarella acl to that [ __ ] i tried i
used to do this [ __ ]
it's really hard russian right there
yeah
thank you thank you
brittany griner something's good because
i'm wearing that
lock her up for now i don't know how do
i look hella russian oh you know what
that's interesting i wonder what russian
news says about
[ __ ]
like she brought drugs in yeah i think
it probably is something like that yeah
it must be it must be very simple no
because dude is like i don't know is cbd
[ __ ] drugs even like but i guess over
there it is
she's smuggling so many drugs that's
what they probably said to us cbd is
like a candle a marijuana scented candle
like nobody really thinks it's drugs
there was a time though when people like
treated weed like it was crack oh yeah
yeah it wasn't too long ago 15 years ago
madness area yeah for sure they had
whole like weird ass videos about it
very true too some states still do
hello people are still in jail for
marijuana oh yeah right now yeah which
is crazy what's that
what's the equivalent of like so she
goes there brings drugs gets arrested
everyone or not everyone but a lot of
americans are like no let her out that's
not it should be fine like what's the
equivalent of someone from russia coming
here and doing something cutting
someone's head we're all like you can't
[ __ ] do that man and he's like in
russia it's cool like what's that
cutting someone's head off and then
cutting bear's head off and swapping
them
like come on
the real thing
i thought you guys like halloween
you guys don't like halloween
just riding a bear
you know what you know what makes me not
this isn't russia but that's the way
that i view some like uh domestic abuse
things you know like some people come
from countries where you it's cool it's
like all right i disagree with my wife
all the time yeah i hit her with shoot
yeah but if only one shoot would just
be one yeah
did you walk into a [ __ ] women's like
[ __ ] speech thing why is she talking
why are you talking on stage
i think bull rap plays that the best or
you're you're in the you're in the
audience and then you're clapping
and his chicks are like oh no those are
that's for me huh
those are for me huh
you